i read that you have oprah winfrey's
actual phone number which i don't think
a lot of people have
i didn't know i had a number right so
anyway me and oprah were doing this talk
and what do you mean a talk you mean a
talk from for
for in front of an audience or or just
no no over over zoom
like this right before i think for like
a live web
chat and she called me afterwards
and the number came up and it was just
to say that i really enjoyed that was
really great thanks for spending the
time you know what i mean very
considerate in that way it's nice yeah
so i saved that number as
oprah thinking deep down it's almost
certainly not her number but
it's clearly a way should i ever need to
contact her
and then on the show one night
in the most organic way because our show
has literally just become a group of
people having a conversation
in a lovely way um we were talking about
businesses that we could we could start
that would make us a load of money i was
like what we need we need a brand
ambassador
we need to piggyback a brand and our
drummer guillermo said what about if
oprah
launches a branch of hotels which is
hotels all these things and we were all
like oh my god
we're going to make a billion dollars
and we were choking around and we were
like how do we contact oprah
we can get to gail we don't know what to
do and then i said hang on a minute i've
this is like on the show genuinely just
completely organized i've got a number
it's almost certainly not her shall we
call it
and we did on loudspeaker and oprah
picked up
and then i immediately got terrified i
thought this is
surely the worst thing you can do to
oprah winfrey is call her
and she's thrown around the air live
yeah i mean without prep
right yeah but she was pretty incredible
and she actually quite liked the idea
served with absolutely room service menu
exactly and sent me a text saying i
never answer the phone
to numbers i don't know and i don't know
why i did but aren't you like me like i
go oh she must think i'm such a [ __ ]
[ __ ] like she gave me her number she
didn't want to be bothered and have me
call her on her show
you know it is a lot of paranoia
involved in that oh there's paranoia
involved in everything but that's
i know yes and then very luckily and
thankfully she
at the moment that i started to think
hang on a minute we should probably just
cut that out the show
that's not fair to call someone during
the show you know what i mean because
obviously
live she sent a text going that was
hilarious
and i was like okay let's carry on